the suicide bombers struck in the
afternoon at an Afghan army Special
Forces Base at risk or 25 kilometers
from Afghanistan's capital Kabul the
Taliban claimed responsibility for the
last week there has been apprehension on
the streets of Kabul that the Taliban
would launch a violent backlash in
response to president Trump's
cancellation of peace talks so far a
major response hasn't materialized
inside the city one rocket landed close
to the US Embassy in the Green Zone
there was little damage and no
casualties the lack of attacks is being
seen by some as a positive they are
still thinking that there is a
possibility for resumption of attack so
if there were attacks in Kabul they will
further exasperate the situation we did
not want it's a sign a sign of hope for
Allah for that trumpet said the talks
were dead but Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo has indicated the u.s. is still
interested in striking a deal and the
departure of the National Security
Advisor John Bolton who opposed the
Taliban talks is seen as another
encouraging move it has given hope that
there will be a resumption of talks but
there is always a caveat now this
process can go either way either they
will resume that peace talk will either
they will just try to double their power
in go to a very harsh in in deadly
situation there is growing international
pressure for the u.s. to get back to the
negotiating table but also an
expectation that any talks should
include a ceasefire and with good reason
away from the capital the fighting is
reported to have intensified with the
u.s. and the Afghan government forces
claiming big successes against the
Taliban the Afghan army says it captured
this base in Badakhshan province on
Wednesday after five years in Taliban
hands the u.s. claims its recent aerial
bombing attacks killed 1000 Taliban
fighters in a four-day period and those
bombardments may be affecting Taliban
morale as well in Kunar province more
than 150 Taliban and ISIL fighters has
surrendered to government forces but the
civilians caught in the fighting are
still paying a high price
heavenly Montessori cazuca many
civilians are still being killed as the
fighting intensifies we've asked all
sides to reduce the use of force in
heavily populated areas but they don't
listen to us there is some hope that
peace talks will be resumed but probably
not until after the forthcoming Afghan
presidential elections they've always
been a catalyst for Taliban attacks and
violence but with the prospects of new
talks many here are hoping that this
time it will be different Tony Bertie al
Jazeera Kabul